pardon je suis en retard on perd pas
plus de temps on y va directement vous
laver réclamé aujourd'hui nouvel épisode
de détestissimo on va retourner faire un
petit tour sur les forums santé pour
voir ce qui se raconte de beau et de
moins beau
j'aime bien mais je sais pas je
ouais un peu un peu les trois non
c'est comment plus j'ai ma cabane là qui
est hyper cool on sera tellement mieux
là-bas pour discuter
attendez
je tente un truc
voilà donc c'est ici que ça va se passer
maintenant c'est cool hein petite déco
sympa et tout
je voulais faire le tour je vais me je
vais me changer je reviens après le
générique
[Musique]
et ouais vous avez vu nouveau décor et
nouveau générique et si vous avez été
attentif à la fin du nouveau générique
vous avez vu le nouveau logo il y a même
deux nouveaux logos mais attention c'est
pas tout il y a aussi une
[Musique]
d'accord bon ben on y va alors déjà pour
être très clair d'emblée le cancer ça
n'est pas contagieux y compris la
leucémie du coup qui est une sorte de
cancer du sang après il y a certains
trucs certaines infections par exemple
qu'on peut retrouver dans le sang et qui
peuvent provoquer certains types de
cancers du coup est-ce qu'il y aurait un
risque de les transmettre pendant une
transfusion et que ça finisse par donner
un cancer à la personne transfusée et
ben il y a des études qui ont été menées
sur le sujet et aucune n'est arrivé à
cette conclusion et de toute façon pour
répondre à la question ces histoires
d'infection là ça concerne même pas les
leucémies donc bon par contre pour
donner son sang il faut être en bonne
santé pour protéger ceux qui vont être
transfusées mais aussi pour protéger les
donneurs et les donneuses parce que si
tu es déjà affaibli par une maladie et
qu'en plus on vient te prendre ton sang
bof donc à quelques exceptions près en
France si on a un cancer y compris une
leucémie donc on peut pas donner son
sang même si on est en rémission ça
changera peut-être un jour mais pour
l'instant c'est comme ça bonjour
J'aimerais savoir s'il y a en France on
pratique je me suis mariée il y a 4 mois
et impossible de consommer le mariage
j'ai vu une gynécologue qui m'a dit que
mon anatomie était très étroite et que
l'opération serait peut-être nécessaire
je voudrais faire l'intervention en
France mais je trouve pas si vous avez
des pistes ça serait génial d'accord
donc on change de registreur alors déjà
avant de parler de l'hyménotomie on va
parler un peu de
limon c'est une membrane c'est un repli
de la muqueuse vaginale qui se trouve
autour de l'orifice du vagin et parfois
qui bouche plus ou moins l'entrée juste
petit aparté vous avez déjà entendu dire
que quand on a un vagin on saigne
forcément après le premier rapport
sexuel parce qu'il y a un truc qui se
déchire et ce truc qui est censé se
rompre cette espèce de sceller là de
garantie de virginité qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est
que non pas du tout énorme bullshit
pourtant on trouve encore ça écrit texto
dans certains dictionnaires pas dans
celui de l'Académie de médecine par
contre mais ça fait pas longtemps alors
pourquoi bullshit bah déjà parce que la
majorité des vagins et équipés d'un
hymen mais pas tous puis ensuite parce
que des emails il y en a de plusieurs
tailles de plusieurs formes différentes
plus ou moins élastiques donc il se
déchire pas forcément parfois il peut
juste s'élargir un peu ou se détendre
mais on reparlera de ça dans une
prochaine vidéo en attendant je vous
mets quand même dans la description de
la vidéo un lien vers un TEDx super
clair qui a été fait sur le sujet et
donc pour répondre à la question
initiale l'imménotomie c'est le fait de
couper un petit peu l'hymen oui quand
vous voyez ectomie dans un mot ça veut
dire qu'on retire un truc mais quand
vous voyez au Tommy ça veut dire qu'on
fait une espèce d'ouverture et comme
j'ai dit tout à l'heure des emails bah
il y en a un peu de tous les styles et
de toutes les formes comme tous les
autres organes du corps humain en fait
mais attention il y a plein d'autres
raisons qui peuvent expliquer que les
rapports sexuels sont difficiles comme
le vaginisme par exemple mais ça aussi
on en reparlera dans une prochaine vidéo
donc du coup avant de vous faire opérer
consulter bien un ou une gynéco pour
être sûr que le souci vient bien de
l'hymen
et hésitez pas à prendre plusieurs avis
je me prive de magret fumer jusqu'à
février 2023 là j'avoue que c'est un
sujet qui date de décembre dernier et
qui est dans la rubrique psychologie je
sais pas quoi dire j'ai fait des
recherches j'ai essayé de voir si
c'était une expression ou si c'était une
espèce de métaphore d'un truc j'ai rien
trouvé j'ai même regardé si l'excès de
ma greffumé ça pouvait pas par hasard
provoquer des troubles psychiatriques
non plus donc là je sais pas de quoi on
parle exactement alors à part que bah à
priori à l'heure actuelle la personne en
question a repris la consommation de ma
greffe fumée vu la date
si vous avez une idée je vous écoute
bonjour est-ce que le stress peut
provoquer de l'apnée du sommeil ah
l'apnée du sommeil ça c'est un sujet
hyper intéressant parce que ça peut
littéralement vous épuiser mais vous
pouvez l'avoir sans même mettre au
courant je vous invite à retourner voir
la vidéo qu'on avait fait sur le sujet
avec Ben de Nota Bene parce qu'il
explique tout ça très très bien et
surtout il raconte comment ça a changé
sa vie depuis qu'il a trouvé ce qu'il
avait alors pour ce qui est du stress
clairement c'est le genre de truc qu'on
retrouve dans tous les troubles du
sommeil mais a priori pour l'apnée du
sommeil bah ça joue pas tellement ce qui
peut causer des syndromes de l'apnée du
sommeil c'est plutôt des trucs
morphologiques en fait genre le surpoids
des problèmes ORL ou des histoires au
niveau de la langue ou de la mâchoire
par exemple mais si vous avez un doute
sur le fait que vous faites de l'apnée
du sommeil surtout parlez-en à votre
médecin et faites un test de dépistage
vraiment ça vaut le coup et tant qu'à
faire faites quelque chose pour votre
stress aussi ça fera pas de mal est-ce
que le gland de lait existe vraiment le
gland de lait vous connaissez de la même
manière qu'on a des dents de lait le
gland de lait c'est le petit bout de
chair IR provisoire que les enfants ont
au bout du pénis à la puberté il tombe
de lui-même ou alors on l'arrache on
l'accrochant à une ficelle elle-même
attachée à une poignée de porte vous
connaissez sûrement truc et puis la
forme définitive repousse on appelle ça
le glandes sagesse alors est-ce que ça
existe vraiment
mais non pas du tout c'est une légende
urbaine je dis ça sans jugement mais je
dis ça très sérieusement parce que j'ai
vu passer plein de questions là-dessus
il y a des gens qui y croient vraiment
le glandelais ça n'existe pas donc pour
que les choses soient bien claires read
my lips le gland de lait ça n'existe pas
imaginez la gueule de la petite souris
bonjour j'ai 16 ans et mon tennis mesure
environ 5 cm au repos mais en érection
il devient entre 18 et 20 cm j'ai
entendu parler du pénis de sang mais
j'aimerais avoir plus d'informations
va-t-il devenir gros au repos est-ce que
c'est un problème de puberté j'attends
avec impatience votre réponse merci
après le glandelais le pénis de sens
donc alors les gens urbaines
ça existe vraiment le pénis de sang par
opposition au pénis de chair non pas
celle-là mais alors c'est quoi ça pénis
de chair pénis de sang je suis un pénis
de chair d'un pénis de ça un pénis de
chair c'est un pénis qui a une taille en
érection qui est assez proche de sa
taille au repos il grossit un peu il
s'allonge un peu mais pas beaucoup il
gagne surtout en rigidité et donc le
pénis de sang dont nous parle notre
camarade là à l'inverse sa taille elle
augmente de façon plus spectaculaire
avec l'érection ok mais de là à passer
de 5 à 20 cm et bah figurez-vous qu'une
étude a été menée sur le sujet
cette étude est là d'abord permis de
confirmer l'existence de ces deux types
de pénis le pénis de chair et le pénis
de sang les showers et les groudels
d'abord les pénis de sang sont une
minorité du coup quand ils se croisent
ils se check genre
mais ce qui est vrai par contre c'est
que les trois quarts des personnes
étudiées ont un pénis de chair et Il
gagne en moyenne 3,1 cm en érection
contre 5,3 cm pour les pénis de sang
donc on est loin des 15 cm gagner par
notre ami là mais bon ça reste des
moyennes autre enseignement la taille
moyenne des pénis de chair en érection
et de 13,1 cm contre 15,5 cm pour les
pénis de sang ça voudrait dire que tout
le monde part à peu près de 10 cm au
repos mais que les pénis de sang
hygrossissent plus et qu'au bout du
compte ils sont plus longs mais pour en
revenir à notre camarade qui se demande
si ça va changer en grandissant par en
vieillissant et ben la même étude a
démontré que les porteurs de pénis de
sang sont généralement sont plus jeunes
et célibataire est-ce que ça veut dire
que ça va changer quand il va prendre de
l'âge et qui va se marier pas sûr bon
alors attention l'étude avoir besoin
d'être confirmé par d'autres études
parce qu'elle a été menée sur un panel
de la population pas vraiment
représentatif mais quand même on apprend
des trucs et surtout n'oubliez pas ce
truc important des pénis il y en a de
toutes les tailles et de toutes les
formules comment l'a dit tout à l'heure
pour l'hymen et pour les vulves de
manière générale donc aucun complexe à
avoir chacun est différent chacun est
normal chacun sa vulve chacun son pénis
vulve pénis voilà c'est une nouvelle
page qui s'ouvre pour BTC et en plus de
ce changement esthétique d'image il va y
avoir aussi d'autres changements on va
continuer bien sûr les sujets classiques
les sujets habituels sur la santé au
sens large et le corps humain en général
mais comme j'ai dit souvent tout est lié
et la santé c'est pas juste la santé
physique donc on va parler un peu plus
souvent de santé mentale et de santé
sexuelle tout ça ça va être en plus donc
il va y avoir plus de vidéos mais tout
ça c'est pareil je vais en reparlerai un
petit peu sur mes réseaux sociaux donc
n'hésitez pas mais là tout de suite DTC
c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite donc pour de
nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de
vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez-vous bien et surtout portez-vous
bien